250 what are you me personally I like to
be in control control V
I can tell okay always
all right and money is associated with
control what about you guys
70 30.
wait wait wait wait sorry I'm 100 type
of guy but that's only because I expect
something for that 100 so I can't be
giving you 100 and you're not trusting
my leadership and even in like like but
that doesn't mean I don't want a woman
to show me that she'll spend for me or
do anything but more time I'm always
gonna spend but one time I might not
spend I might look at you like just just
do it you know what I mean yeah be
willing yeah willing that's it because
that's the thing it's just like if you
like I think a lot of chicks if you if
they get into that kind of routine of
you pay for everything yeah
the bill come you might just take a
vaccine you might just wait can see what
happens right for me she's not even
looking rap she's just looking down
yeah yeah Michael and I I swear to God
yeah there's been like I've done that
before I've done that before and it and
one time one time she just you're like
nah I'll never link you not because I
haven't got the money but I just want to
just uh you know you know the word the
the maddest thing about that the girls
will be like oh guess what I went up
with this guy yeah and he did he took
long to pay like he was looking at me I
was just looking at my mind
I could never I could never go on a date
no no the reality is
hold on hold on the reality is you women
that do that you're the waste of men
yeah
hold on and there's no there's no shame
for these girls again it goes back to
what we're saying there's no shame for
girls being waste men I want to start
calling girls waste members
I don't understand her like in this I
I've been on a few days I've definitely
I've offered to I always make sure that
I pay half if not I paid the full Bill a
couple times just because I know I'm
never seen that guy again and I would
feel bad if he paid for my whole thing
and I was to never that's mad he's paid
for like what 100 pounds for a meal to
never see me again that's crazy that's
the situation in which I'm there like
karma is real someone's gonna get me
back in the future I can't do that they
like if if it's a case of like I know
for a million percent this man is going
to be a part of my life cool you get
this one one day next one I can get that
I think that the the date thing where a
man always has to pay is wild that that
for me for me for me I'm I'm Nigerian in
it so I have a certain way I was brought
up in terms of how I see my dad treat my
mom etc etc So currently based on my
financial stays I said I'm a 70 guy
honest but if if ideally I was where I
wanted to be financially it would be 100
[Music]
because there's certain respect level
exceptions
the girl's not gonna respect you but
she's gonna sleep with her work husband
or she's gonna sleep with someone like
King riches bro
why do you assume that no not the
postman not the postman the Milkman he
views that but why would you have seen
that if a girl is looking after her man
that she is cheating she can't respect
him no I'm not saying I'm not saying
automatically but at the end of the day
usually if a woman resp if a woman
doesn't respect a man bro bro she could
do anything
yeah as I said in the scenario yeah like
say like for instance they're married
yeah so they're already locked in yeah
the man just he's just now he's Just
Smiles anymore that's the one that she
wants let me understand where you're
coming from I want to hear the one voice
you want to hear thanks what I'm saying
yeah is that boom in this scenario yeah
boom the man is just [ __ ] yeah you don't
have no please he can't support he can't
do nothing the woman is the support now
she's the captain but financially Bravia
really and truly she's going to be
looking down on that man what did we say
what did we agree with earlier hypergamy
women like to date up do you get what
I'm saying if you have support in the
guy you're not looking up no more you're
looking down like breath he's become
your child can I no can I can I say
something can I get can I say something
can I say something really quickly right
this year it was something like the
highest amount of divorces in the 30s
um like that's because of lockdown
that's why I know just say what you were
saying say what uh last thing quickly
sorry um yeah so when so we were talking
about how many divorces happened now
like marriage is not what it used to be
when before when you get married that's
it that's you and them for life that's
that's what it was meant to be right
right but now I come from a culture
right I'm Sri Lankan I'm an Asian girl
right the culture I am from I did I am
blessed that I did not see this in the
family I am from but I know of so many
women that were in marriages and yeah it
was 60 years but they were not happy in
those marriages but they could not leave
they did not have the means they weren't
educated they because that their goal
their expectation of them was get
married have a child that was it look
after the husband that was all that was
expected of them so when we sit there
and say to we like women now and our pet
our mothers are saying to us get your
daughters educated make sure that they
they can they can look after themselves
not because they said they necessarily
want to like yeah when I'm in a
relationship I want to let my man lead
however if if God forbid something awful
happens and I need to leave that
marriage I'm not trapped you already
gone into your marriage and you're
already thinking about leaving no but
that's not that's not it it is it's not
thinking about leaving it's knowing that
look at the end of the day in
relationships it doesn't always go right
there are stuff that you don't
necessarily learn until you are married
to that person or you do live with that
person right and that anything can
happen I can trust a million percent in
my mind I could I could give him all the
freedom in the world he has all the
freedom if he's free to cheat if I'm in
a relationship with him if he cheats any
single but he's free to make that
decision if you ask you a question can I
ask you a question before I get to the
Super Chat I've gotta jump to the Super
Chat here are you a feminist
um I wouldn't not the not the definition
of feminism that is today because I feel
like feminism today is not what feminism
meant true what I I would not I would
not sit there and say that I'm a
feminist in the definition of what
feminism is now because I feel like
feminism is if anything anti-men that's
not what feminism was about well I'm a
feminist I I do believe that women and
men should have equal playing field in
life I.E you can both vote we can both
get paid the same if we're doing the
same job that's what I believe in I do
believe that there are differences in
men and women I.E
um a man cannot carry a child that's a
fact that is the what do a woman does
all right and in that respect if oh if a
man wants to lead in a relationship then
it's about whether it works for those
two people each relationship is one is
not compatibility yeah it's about their
compatibility if that if this if there
is a man that is willing to be like yeah
I'm a trophy husband I say oh I clean up
home I do all of that and the woman's
going out and working who's anybody else
to judge that nobody it works for them I
need to jump to the Super Chat sorry
sorry I need to jump to the super chats
here
um and we might need people to move or
something like that all right guys uh
we're gonna change over the whole panel
actually because we got a lot of people
here today uh so if everybody can just
quickly switch over uh the girls on the
couch in the middle and then everyone
has to fill up on the side you guys can
go on the panel thank you
foreign
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible